MAGGIE LINDSAY: What
gives me the opportunity
to grow my imagination,
I really like that.
I like learning things about
the way the world works
and seeing how each
little piece is connected
to every other little piece,
to create this beautiful planet
that we live on.
SUNGGYE HONG: Visual
impairments should not
serve as the
barrier for students
who are blind or visually
impaired in choosing
their own path.
So we came up with a
very capable team members
from the U of A and also
throughout the country, who
have been working and
specialized in this topic,
and put together
around two key words
project based learning
and mentorship.
And this is a
three-year project that
is being funded by the
National Science Foundation.
KATHRYN BUSBY:
This is a great way
to get students integrated
with each other,
whether they are blind or
visually impaired or not.
And I hope that they
take away acceptance
for each other, no matter what.
I hope they take away the
fact that they can do science,
because I think they may get
the message that they can't when
they totally, totally can.
I hope they take away an
appreciation for the outdoors
and carry it forward
into their lives.
MAGGIE LINDSAY: In some
ways you learn more
through not using your eyes.
I think, because
the world we live in
is so visual, sighted people
tend to overlook those things,
just because they use
their eyes so much.
So since I can't
use my eyes, I had
to find all the other
ways I could do it,
and I ended up learning
in some ways more.